foreign
[Music]
this was a comment that somebody left on
YouTube on one of the shows this week
that I thought was interesting and it's
not looking for advice it's actually
giving advice I just think it's good so
pbd park Biz says parenting without
screens is easy you just have to join in
and most parents won't I don't think my
parenting is better or my child is well
behaved with a screen they're upset for
a minute and then they forget for a few
it takes a week to break the Habit that
most kids have just take it away and
don't give it back the screen's
referring to be strong
here's the part that's most important
spend time with them let them be in the
room while you work let them ask
1450 questions even if it's annoying
stop being a child yourself and parent
I think that's extraordinary advice it's
also very basic and it should be obvious
but uh the best advice often is and this
is exactly right the first thing when it
comes to to Modern parenting anyway this
is like one of the number one challenges
is the screen it's the it's the siren
song of all these screens that are
constantly beckoning to your children
and to us and threatening to totally
take over and absorb every minute of Our
Lives
um and so you've got it if you want to
have a happy and fulfilled family and
marriage and you want Happy fulfilled
children and you want to have some
chance also of actually raising your own
children of you being the one who raises
them and that their moral formation and
their spiritual formation and all of
that in their education
is largely up to you if you want some
hope of that then you've got to be able
to sever their ties and their dependency
on the screen and you just got to be
able to do it and in some ways I don't
have a lot of
sympathy for parents that
like don't know how to do this or they
don't want to or they feel bad about it
no yeah if you take the screen away from
your kid maybe that you've already given
them a phone big mistake take it away
say never mind you can't have this phone
it's okay to admit when you made a
mistake as a parent you could say we
made a mistake we you should not have
this we're going to take it away you
take away that you know you severely cut
down on TV time on uh time with video
games if you do that yeah the kid's
gonna be upset they'll be in a huff
whatever who cares
you know you cannot allow yourself to be
emotionally manipulated by your children
you just can't allow it and what you
should know as a parent is that there
are basically like two kinds of hurt
that your child might experience
there's the discomfort that he might
feel because he's not getting something
that he wants and yet shouldn't have and
you're taking that thing away or you're
limiting his time with that thing and
that makes him uncomfortable that makes
him bored and he's upset about that
there's like that kind of hurt okay and
then there's the real hurt there's a you
know either emotional or physical where
there's something deeper going on first
kind of hurt really shouldn't bother you
I could say for for me as a parent it
just doesn't if my kids are whining
because they want something and I don't
give it to them they want it they want
to watch TV and they can't they want to
you know junk food snack and I say no
you can't have that they want some soda
and I say I'm not gonna give you soda
and they get they get in a snit about it
that does that has no impact on me at
all like those kinds of emotions from my
kid that's like you got to get over that
that that's just I'm Teflon with that
that bounces right off me I don't care
now again there's there's the deeper
kind of emotional hurt that your child
might feel and that you should take
seriously I mean there are many examples
of that just recent example for me I was
uh when I was most recently going on a
trip to another speak another college
and uh my son was like very upset that I
was leaving again so I've been traveling
a lot and he was really upset about and
he was in tears and he was now of course
that's something deeper that's like I
want to spend time with Dad you're not
here you know
um so then I'm gonna sit down and we're
going to have a real conversation about
that okay and that does you know that's
the kind of thing that that's a gut
punch that you actually feel as a parent
but there's other stuff where they're
just whining because they want something
you got to be able to
you know be be unfazed by that entirely
and then yes as the comment points out
you take the screens away you take these
things away
and especially when the children are
younger you can quite easily replace
that in a way that they will find more
than satisfying and sufficient if you're
if you spend time with them yourself
what with a dirty little secret which is
not much of a secret is that most
parents this is exactly why they put
their kids in front of the screens
because they don't want to spend time
with their kids
because they consider it taxing or
annoying or right could ask so many
questions or whatever but you you you're
a parent and this is what your child
wants it wants to be around you wants to
spend time with you especially for
younger kids
and I think it's one of the biggest
mistakes that we make as parents of
younger kids is that we don't give
children that time that they need and
that attention that they need you can't
give attention all the time right where
they think the world revolves around
them they do want your attention they do
just want to they want to just be around
you they want to do the things that
you're doing you don't always have to do
childlike things you can incorporate
them into the things that you're doing
they really like that they want to do
that
but you have a lot of parents where
they're annoyed by it they don't want to
they don't want to deal with it and so
they push the kids away they say I just
go watch TV not now and then the time
inevitably comes when they become
teenagers or maybe even before that or
Suddenly It's like a a switch is flipped
and now they don't even want to be
around you anymore they don't want your
attention anymore and when that happens
we hear the story a million times from
parents that's when they look back and
they think of all those times when the
kids were younger and begging for their
attention and and and that's all they
want like when you're a parent of a
young child this is your biggest problem
it's just that your kids like you too
much and they want to be around you too
much it's like one of the biggest it's
one of the biggest issues that parents
complain about is when they have young
kids which is not really a problem at
all and once the kid gets older it
doesn't want to be around you anymore
because they're going through their
teenage phase you look back on it and
realize oh that was never a problem that
was a beautiful thing I wish I had
I wish I'd spent time with them when
they wanted it maybe they would still
want my attention now if I had given it
to them back then you've heard me talk
about how important it is to have a VPN
to protect your online privacy but
choosing a VPN you trust is equally as
important I like to do research on my
sponsors and I only recommend Brands to
my listeners that I believe in that I
will personally use and I do use
expressvpn I think about all the times
you've used Wi-Fi at a coffee shop Hotel
even a friend's house without expressvpn
every site you visit can be logged by
the Admin of that Network and that's
true even when you're in uh incognito
mode it still can happen so expressvpn
is an app that encrypts all of your
network data reroutes it through a
network of secure servers so that your
private online activity stays private
expressvpn works on all of your devices
it's super easy to use the app has one
button and it's a real big button you
just tap it and you're good to go stop
letting strangers invade your online
privacy use my Link at expressvpn.com
walshyt to get three extra months free
that's
expressvpn.com
walshyt all right Carter says Mr Walsh I
listen to and enjoy your show very much
I would Hazard to say that I agree
wholeheartedly with your views on
marriage and the family being a
traditionally raised Catholic myself
I've come to understand the beauty and
joy that marriage and the family can
bring into one's life however I find it
impossible to find anyone that I'm
interested in dating much less marrying
who resides anywhere near me I was
wondering if you would have any advice
or words different from the typical be
patient or you need to get out more I'll
admit that I have reclusive Tendencies
and that I mostly just go to work and
then go home with that said most of the
young adult groups in my area would
consist of women in professions which
would not allow for traditional marriage
and family which is how I'd want to
raise children I also don't like bars
they're typically loud dark and crowded
which usually causes me to shut down not
to mention I likely wouldn't find the
kind of woman I'm interested in at a bar
combine this all with the fact that most
of my dreams that have had any True
Value have all ended in Failure I find
it hard to maintain hope that there is
someone out there for me perhaps you
have the Golden Nugget of wisdom that
will help me hold on to hope I guess my
first Golden Nugget of wisdom Carter is
to stop expecting anyone to have a
golden nugget of wisdom that's going to
solve your problem
nugget the path forward and the
solutions the potential Solutions I
think are are obvious to you in fact you
you dismiss some of them outright you
said well don't tell me this those are
those are some of the answers you
dismiss for example the young adult
groups in your area because you assume
you say well they would consist of the
kind of people that I don't want to be
around and I would go here but I'm not
going to find people there and I would
go there but there's gonna be the wrong
people there sounds like you're just
sort of assuming all of that he's right
you know and you're not actually trying
you're not actually putting yourself out
there and as much as you don't want to
hear it that is part of the solution for
you potentially is you got to put
yourself out there more I mean you said
that you you go to work you come home
you don't really socialize with anyone
you don't go anywhere else how would you
meet anybody in that case even if it's
uncomfortable and I totally get that as
an introverted person myself I'm not
into forced group activities I'm not
into that but I did some of that when I
was single because I realized it got to
put myself out there I got to get
outside of my comfort zone a little bit
focus on improving yourself
to whatever extent you can and then the
other practical piece of advice that you
didn't rule out at least from the start
is that this is a big one expand your
search area so you're telling me to
begin with that there's no one in your
area who you find worthy and I'm I'm
willing to bet that there are women even
in your area there aren't many great
things about the modern dating scene but
maybe the only one is that you can EXT
you're not relegated just to where you
physically live you can expand your
search area by using dating sites and
that sort of thing and you have to be
willing to travel you know my wife when
I met her she she lived two and a half
hours away so it wasn't like she was
halfway around the country across the
country but she was two and a half hours
away and so that meant that like to see
each other took effort and time that's
not a bad thing though you know when you
have to put in to begin with you have to
put the effort in and the time in just
to see each other and be around each
other I think that can be a great
advantage Ashley says I've been married
for six years and with my spouse for
almost 14 years yes it took him that
long to propose my question is how often
should a couple say I love you my
husband is not outwardly emotional
hardly at all unless he's upset we next
to never say I love you should I
initiate this more what are your
thoughts yeah you should initiate it
more uh just tell him you you love him
also you could talk to him about this
maybe you have but I'm always surprised
by how often it seems that people have
these kinds of issues in their marriage
which are like relatively minor and then
you talk to them you find out well
they've actually never talked about it
let me say uh we don't really need to be
here so this is something you could
bring up to him not in a nagging way not
in a scolding way nothing like that not
an accusatory way once again things that
could have been brought to my attention
yesterday if you find a time when you're
both in a good mood and you're sitting
on the couch or something and you just
tell them you know I know you love me
but it would it makes me feel good to
hear the words from you and so I'd like
for us to start saying it more to each
other I think I think he would respond
to that
um if you said that to him
and it is important to say the words you
know it's not like you have to be on a
schedule where it's like well you got to
say I love you uh 14 times a week you
know and if it's been a few days you
haven't said it then you got to catch up
it's not that but you should the words
do matter to spouses and also matters to
your kids I think we should also be
telling your kids that you love them all
right this will be the last one this
from Jacob says Matt I recently did the
impossible I matched with a fellow sweet
baby on Tinder that that does seem to be
there but on Tinder is where you found
the fellow sweet baby wow I didn't know
we had a presence on Tinder
I don't know if I'm happy about that or
not as you can imagine I was extremely
excited and we quickly began discussing
our views and learning about each other
we exchanged numbers and socials and
began talking I asked her if she wanted
kids and I also joke that maybe we
should move to Tennessee together so we
can rub elbows with the fine people the
daily wire after a couple of days I tell
her that we should go out after the
holidays to which she seemed surprised
and told me that she thought I was just
her political buddy because I didn't oh
man sorry man
because I didn't flirt enough in the
beginning and that she found someone
else this genuinely
her know I wanted it
today at a dating app do you think this
was her way of trying to Let Me Down
Easy or is she just evil and in need of
being cancer she's not evil uh she's a
member of the sweet baby so she's baby
gang so we know she's not evil to begin
with I think this was yeah her trying to
let you down easy
now on her Parts you should be more
honest with you but people don't feel
always comfortable being that honest
with with uh especially someone they
don't know
and
yeah I think we can assume that she
realized that you're not on Tinder
looking for a quote political buddy
you're such a good friend right the
bestest
oh one of the worst kind of like friend
of all the ways to friend zone someone I
think maybe that's one of the worst ways
you can do it did you do anything wrong
that made it so that she lost interest
that quickly it's impossible for me to
say based on this short description of
the exchange that I have here if I were
you I wouldn't have made the comment
about moving to Tennessee together and I
know you phrased it as a joke sorry I'm
making a go of it in a new city it
probably wasn't entirely a joke was it
it was you were kind of like feeling
things out not that you were going to
move with her that moment but when you
just met someone on Tinder you haven't
even met them in person and you're
already even jokingly bringing up moving
somewhere together uh that might have
freaked her out a little bit
other than that you know based on this
doesn't sound like you did anything
wrong and uh you didn't let it linger
too long I think oftentimes the mistake
a guy will make is that you you I guess
what they call the talking phase and you
do the talking phase for weeks and weeks
and months and then finally York up the
courage to say hey maybe we should
actually like physically go out together
and at that point she's already lost
interest identity has brought me to you
what but uh you talked to her for a few
days and asked her on a date that sounds
reasonable to me but she
wasn't interested found someone else
these things happen get back out there
don't let that discourage you and we
will end on that encouraging note as we
uh finish up here Godspeed
[Music]
foreign